now we're going to talk about distance
distance between two vectors
that's a concept that comes immediately
from the idea
of norm which is a which is a roughly
the length of a vector
okay so if i have two vectors
let's suppose these are two vectors or
three vectors right
uh then the euclidean distance between
the if a
and b represent two positions is simply
the norm of a minus b
um and so some people would write that
this way so
dist is the distance function says the
distance between a and b is the norm of
a minus b
and you know the picture might be this
that's the that's the point a
that's the position b in this case
b minus a is the vector
shown by the blue arrow which in this
case is two comma one
if we believe if if the units on that
grid our units
and then the distance between a and b
would then be
b minus a that's the same of course as a
minus b at the same thing so that's
that's the distance between two vectors
and it agrees with the ordinary distance
you know that you learned about
in your algebra class you know certainly
for
dimensions one two and three it's the
same
sometimes people also will look at the
rms deviation
between a and b uh so that's the r it's
but it's just
it's just the distance divided by square
root n okay so that so you automatically
get distance now what's new here is
though
we can now talk about the distance
between a 100 vectors
namely vectors with dimension 100. um
that's interesting
you can't visualize that now you can
pretend to visualize that
you can claim you know in front of your
friends that you could say well i can
visualize
there's one vector and there's the other
and the distance between them is 12. i
told you i can see it
but no one can visualize a hundred
dimensions so that doesn't really make
any sense
okay um now we can get to the triangle
inequality
and i can i can explain how it got its
name
so here's how it works um think of of
three positions a b and c these are all
three vectors
um now the edge lengths and i've drawn
that down here so there's here's a
b and c um now what we're going to do is
the edge lengths
are well the edge between a and b has
length norm a minus b
the length between b and c is norm b
minus c for example
and the length between of the just the
distance between
a and c the length of this triangle side
is norm a minus c
okay and so we're going to apply the
triangle inequality the triangle
inequality
says that the sum of two vectors so
first of all i've just
i've added b and subtracted b in going
from this equation
uh to this equation so nothing's changed
it's so i have an equal sign here
and now what i'm doing is i'm using the
triangle inequality triangle inequality
says that the norm
of a sum is less than or equal to the
sum of the norms so here i have norm of
a minus b
norm b minus c and what it says is i
mean
it goes goes way back goes to euclid i
guess and basically says the following
it says that the noi that the length of
any side of a triangle
is less than or equal to the sum of the
other two lengths
so that's uh that's what it says so this
that's why this is called the triangle
inequality
the the original uh the the inequality
for norms
um okay
now i'm just as a as a teaser we're
going to talk
about uh some very interesting ideas
that even though norm is a very simple
concept
you can actually already see see that
it's gonna it you can there's hints
that it could get super duper useful so
let me
we'll talk about the concept of a
nearest neighbor um
so if you have two feature vectors for
example
um then the norm of the difference which
is the distance between them that's
called the feature distance
and so what that says is you could talk
about feature you can you have the
concept of
two features two feature vectors being
close or two being very far away
so i mean if we go back to that very
simple example
in of regression we had the house area
as the first component and the second
was the number of bedrooms and so
uh two houses that are close would have
probably the same number of bedrooms and
similar
number of thousands of square feet right
so that would be
in that case the feature distance would
be small but a
a one bedroom you know 900 square foot
house
right would not would have a large
feature distance to
a six bedroom five thousand square foot
house
right so that that's kind of the idea so
we often we have the distance
now that's not a geometric notion of
distance right um
so that's the that that's the that's the
idea okay
so this brings us to this idea of a
nearest neighbor
um it's something you will hear about in
other courses for sure
maybe we'll say something about it too
later but let's see so here
if i have a list of vectors um
then zj one of these vectors is and i
have another vector x
like a query vector then what it will
say
is that among this list of vectors the
one that is
closest to x we're going to call the
nearest neighbor
makes perfect sense right so here's x in
this picture and here's my z's you can
see the six of them
and the distance between x and the z's i
mean
the farthest one maybe is um z1
right so that's the farthest distance um
intermediate you know intermediate
there's various intermediate distances
but it looks like the winner is z3 here
so we you would say that z3 in this
in this tiny baby example here z3 is the
nearest neighbor of
x among z1 dot dot z6
okay and it makes perfect sense i mean
you're basically saying
of this list of vectors which is x
closest
to okay so look now you might ask like
who cares uh but actually immediately
this is a powerful concept in
in uh sort of very basic machine
learning and data analysis it's already
very powerful concept i mean even though
it looks very innocent
um let's look at an example uh which
hopefully will give you a rough idea of
some cool stuff here
okay so um what we're going to do
is we're going to look at feature
vectors which are word count histograms
okay so what we did is we took some
wikipedia articles here
um i guess there's five of them and we
have a dictionary of forty about
four and a half thousand words that's
all okay
um and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take for each of these five
wikipedia articles we take the entire
article and we count the number of words
in our dictionary it appears in each of
those so i don't know what the first
entry in my dictionary is
but i guarantee you that for these i
have five vectors
corresponding to these these wikipedia
pages
right and the first entry tells you
how many times that first dictionary
word appeared in those five articles
okay so that's it now yeah don't even
try
to visualize uh what what a vector in
in with 44 or 23 dimensions is because
you
can't you can pretend you can and you
can in fact if you like you can sort of
pretend that it looks like that
okay but i mean i guess it does look
like that just in 4423 dimensions
okay so let's let's
take a look at what happens now we're
going to calculate the pairwise
distances
of all of all uh six
five of these of these wikipedia pages
okay and and all i all we want to do
is to see kind of see if it makes sense
okay well the first one is the diagonals
are easy because
veteran's day has a vector associated
with it so does uh and if i
if i say what's the distance between a
vector and itself it's zero it's the
norm of zero minus zero so it's zero
so the diagonals are all zero right oh
and by the way it's also
uh this is symmetric in the sense that
the distance between veterans day and
memorial day
which is .095 is actually the same as
the distance between memorial day
and veterans day so i mean of course
right
so by the way in some people when they
give a a table like this
they just omit the bottom half of the
table because you don't need to see it
because it's the same as the top half
okay all right
so now let's dive a little bit deeper
and let's ask ourselves some questions
like among
these five vectors
which two are the closest to each other
okay so and if we just scan across all
this
it is indeed veterans day memorial's day
okay and then you'd ask that's
does that make sense and the answer is
yeah
yeah veterans day and memorial's day are
both wikipedia pages describing
holidays so they are actually related
um in fact they're more closely related
than any of the others
right um we can also ask uh
what would be the second closest pair
and look at that it would be in fact the
academy awards
and the golden globe awards oh by the
way when i say closest i mean
uh the ones that are not the same right
um
that's kind of amazing because it says
that just among these
five things the two that are closest are
the two that just are the two pages that
describe
um that that the two pages that describe
uh holidays
right the next two are ones that
describe two different kinds of
entertainment awards right so something
is happening
and you can kind of imagine why you know
like
i don't know the the word holiday
probably appears in veterans and
memorial or something like that
but but not in the super well okay not
in the golden globe awards something
right um okay um so
it's actually kind of interesting uh see
we could ask all sorts of stuff here
right we could have um
we could say what are the most what's
the farthest distance and the farthest
distance i guess is going to be this the
golden globe awards and
the and the super bowl okay well
yeah those seem pretty far apart um
let me just say a couple things about
about this because you can already do
some pretty cool stuff
um instead of doing it with five
pathetic articles like this
we could do something like this we could
actually
do we could do this for 5 000 articles
and you could have a new article that
you've never seen before
and you could ask what is its nearest
neighbor
uh actually a very common thing to do is
give me
the three nearest neighbors those would
be the one that's closest the second
closest to the third closest so these
are these are kind of things
now what's stunning about this is how
something
pro so profoundly stupid has actually
quote figured out that for example
memorial day
and veterans day are related now let me
remind you how dumb this
is we've taken the wikipedia page
to two wikipedia pages and we have
simply
counted the number of words okay in in
the page
that obviously we have obscured all
meaning they're no longer sentences
they're no longer paragraphs
um this just tells you how many times
each word
occurred i mean that's all it is it's
just really pretty simple
um it doesn't understand english it
doesn't understand
anything at all it simply counts the
words
and when you do that it's kind of cool
that stuff comes up that you recognize
like it figured out that these two
things are close right so
um so we'll we'll we'll talk uh we'll
we'll come back to this kind of stuff
later in in greater detail
but this should just give you a little
hint that even though the concepts we're
working with are embarrassed are
actually really very simple it's just
the distance between two feature vectors
um it's already interesting um i give a
couple of examples uh
someone comes into an er i i take their
i take their feature vector it's a
feature but you know it's 100 long with
different things and
symptoms attributes of the patient all
sorts of other stuff okay
so i take that test they've had results
so i take that hundred vector a thousand
vector doesn't matter i take a thousand
thousand vector and i take that and i
run it against
all the patients we saw in the last five
years okay
that's a whole bunch of each one has a
feature vector and then i say
give me the ten nearest neighbors that
means
show me the patient from the past you
know five years
who had a feature vector closest to my
patient the second closest and so on now
the closest one
is interesting what we can do then is we
can actually do immediately you can
think of cool stuff you can do you could
pull up that file and take a look at it
and say
oh oh not cool oh boy that
that patient developed sepsis on day two
that's really bad so maybe we better put
this one on prophylactic antibiotics
right now
or something like that right um so uh
the point is
it's already like pretty cool uh that
you can already see
just with the concept of feature vector
and distance you can already see
you should be able to see that there's
practical applications like coming up
right i mean give you a perfect example
somebody says
you know go buy me a bond i want this
bond
it's going to be issued by this issuer
and blah blah blah and you're like
there aren't any for sale and you go
then what this would do would say
i would make a feature vector for bonds
and this would
some would say okay in that case go get
me a similar bond
and sure enough you will find a similar
bond that is for sale and you'll buy it
right and so and actually a lot of
things work kind of on
just just stuff like this